I want to discuss something that a few
people have emailed me about lately and
a lot of people are aware that economist
Marxist economist richard wolf was a
college professor of mine years ago the
university of massachusetts and i get
many questions from people say you know
at in high school in econ even AP econ
you really only learn capital what we
call capitalist economics colloquially
right the idea that we have resource
distribution scarcity supply and demand
in a free market that works perfectly
well price floors the Keynesian ideas
etcetera you're not really getting
alternative economic theories in college
unless your college offers a class on
Marxian economics like the University of
Massachusetts did when I was there but
you're not going to get exposed to that
either shouldn't schools be teaching
more than just capitalist economics and
the answer is absolutely the problem is
these economics have become so
stigmatized right if you have a course
in its uh Advanced Placement economics
in high school and it's half traditional
economics what we would call traditional
neoclassical Keynesian type economics
whichever flavor you like and then half
alternative economic theories people
will go nuts people will say this is
your you're teaching kids to be
predisposed to be communist blah blah
blah blah blah and of course the reality
is if presented with multiple economic
theories you were drawn to one that is
not the vulture capitalism that we have
maybe we should pay attention to that
and many people will say that the
problem David is in high school and
college kids hear about the stuff it
sounds so good based on the lack of
development that the brains have when
you're 17 18 19 20 21 you're going to
distort people's minds at a very very at
an age where their minds are so pliable
and you're gonna send them in the wrong
direction we're really ultimately they
will they would always come back to
neoclassical standard economic theory I
don't know that that's true i mean III
think that by college you're able to
make some pretty good judgments about
some things yet hard to think about when
you're 21 what is it going to be like to
be 55 and potentially have kids I mean I
I can't even imagine what that
potentially would be
like and I'm not nearly 55 but I don't
think that we should be not teaching
alternative economic theories because it
would be considered indoctrination
teaching only neoclassical economics is
arguably indoctrination as well because
you're saying hey listen this is the
standard any crazy stuff you hear about
later that's what you should be
skeptical of you should be just as
skeptical of neoclassical economics and
I was told something that's entering the
field of economics is term called
happiness and it's very intangible but
at some point in some cultures and some
people are valuing it much higher than
money in as it should be like if you're
making a million dollars near miserable
yeah why are you doing that what good is
that yeah no no that that the entire
happiness economics field is growing the
behavioral economics feel this is
growing although that it doesn't it's
not really related to economic systems
but it is in the sense that learning
about behavioral economics helps us
understand what elements of our economic
system doin makes do and don't make
sense in this relates to uh from you
know the paradigm of of work connected
to uh so many other areas of life and in
many ways is connected now from a purely
practical perspective some people will
say well a capitalist economics is the
predominant economic system of the world
and thus it should be the focus okay
well maybe economic history should be
more prevalent and these alternative
theories are being taught as historical
realities I don't know but the point I
have is that we have a self-fulfilling
prophecy or a vicious circle where kids
imagine that there's going to be no
alternative to capitalist economics in
part because it's all that they're
taught about and and I think that's
where there's a big big opportunity yeah
and we are a partially socialistic state
we have programs in which we are
providing our people through our tax
dollars yeah back to these people and I
am in the camp that we should be doing
more of this we should be spending say
we take one of the many trillions of
dollars we waste on defense budgets yeah
if we pour that into our education
excuse me and in health care systems I
feel like they they might be free oh
it's perfectly logical and I've said it
might mind the mini-story I tell
is we've got 50 military bases in
Germany could we be just as safe with 25
military bases in Germany and taking the
cost of the 25 we could close and
putting them to other things and of
course the answer is yes why are we
protecting Germany is there something
some well when they're not i mean really
those are their supposedly for strategic
reasons because of the placement in
terms of the the conflicts that we could
potentially be involved in there but
you're making a very good point which is
if the if the idea is really the
protection of america and its interests
abroad we could probably be just a safe
with 25 German bases bases in Germany as
we would with 50